In Jeremiah 10:3-4 says, "For the
customs of the people are vain, for one
cutth a tree out of the forest, the work
of the hands of the workmen with the
axe. They deck it with silver and gold,
and they fasten it with nails and
hammers that it moves not." So, we're
clearly not supposed to do this as
[music] the customs of the people. Which
people? Well, the customs of the pagan
people that God always warns us not to
follow. [music] Many people would say
God made the pine tree. Therefore, it
can't be evil. We can't take another
idol or god and repurpose it to worship
God. Let's just look at the verse. It
says, "Take heed to thyself that thou be
not snared by following them after that
they be destroyed from before thee, and
that thou inquire not after their gods,
saying, How did these nations serve
their gods? And even so will I do
likewise? Thou shalt not do so unto the
Lord thy God. For every abomination to
the Lord, which he hateth, [music] have
they done unto their gods. For even
their sons and their daughters they have
burnt in the fire to their gods. What
things soever I command you, observe to
do [music] it. Thou shalt not add
thereto, nor diminish from it. God has
specific ways in which he wants us to
worship him. We can't repurpose other
ways of doing so or pagan ways [music]
of doing so. That is the the takeaway
from this. We are not supposed to do as
the pagans do. Many people will make
excuses. Even though they said that they
wanted another god to worship while
Moses was on the hill, they still said
it was a feast onto the Lord. You cannot
worship God in a way he tells he tells
you not to. It's still pagan. So you
can't repurpose where Christmas came
from and try to separate [music] it from
that create distance in you so you don't
know and think about it anymore and just
do it just like anyone else is doing. At
least if you really want to worship God,
you can't do that because he knows it's
idolatry. He knows it's paganism. Let's
make God proud and make him the Lord of
our life by not worshiping other things
and putting these holidays that worship
other gods in our